yeah welcome to this video against I oh
man on lohman I don't know it's always
difficult to figure out let's play d6
and okay we got someone requested a
Philly door so let's play a philly door
once once in a while yeah g3 is a very
solid set up not a bad one
what I'd like to do is to play a 6 we
should be seven and b5 okay
yet to be honest I was never really sure
what White's plan is in this kind of
position of course his he's okay and
he's got everything developed and so on
but where exactly is your on your plane
happen sorry that's a bit of a sore
throat here yeah can exchange that and
so on but
okay Knight to f5 okay i want to i mean
95 or so a common move anyway so let's
let's go down and okay
okay maybe mm-hmm I thought just here
and take this maybe you can take with
the pawn I would I have pawn to you form
myself not f5 takes Queen takes as so
nothing takes what the queen is really
really a good for black even okay so now
we have two lights against night and and
let's say problematic a bishop of
doubtful quarter doubtful quality I can
I need to get off the heavy pieces I'd
like to play something like two nights
against bishop at night end game this
would be a would be nice
so I just exchange everything here
if it takes on this heaven I
unfortunately cannot take with the Queen
I can take with with both nights
so what I'm what are suitable plants
here they can activate the Queen Queen
d6
hmm
yeah maybe it wants to go to e7 if I go
here Queen d8 queen-high can / 26
probably I don't really want to play f6f
sex looks la bit ugly maybe king of Asia
just King evade ok King evade is not a
bad move anyway approaching at the
center hmm
okay keep prepared 26
Queen d6 Knight f6 something like this
yeah ok so we played this end game take
requested take pic
not quite sure what's so bad about this
move if you want so I mean it's not not
a big deal okay Kingy one is kinky too
much man makes much more sense maybe but
now it's just saying good gracias okay
is from Argentina right okay so I even
have this was check now so I've got s
it's quite apparent tuned to to
nice-knights so be five before maybe I'm
trying to get them a passport this is
really a bad bishop this is the problem
and he is he has big problems to him to
evict this night from deform okay so
before take it well let's play let's
play have sex first keep it simple
if it takes me five yeah both moves are
good actually Wow another one on light
square sir this is quite surprising
yeah it's okay it's it's bad for him
anyway I see that but
hmm yeah I'm not sure be4 certainly good
for me but I can also take and play 96
switches which is simple and good but
i'm not sure if i want to open up the
position okay let's let's let's play it
play it this way
so I know 926 and I don't know he
doesn't really have a move King III i
take c to King d3i take f4 and g2
now neither form ok maybe he's got
Queenie's no King III I can take here
get to get to age 5 so take h5 now
check
you need to prevent an ID see form
so how to how to get this knight Knight
to f4 Knight to f4 and then play g5 if
he if he attacks it I probably need to
return a pawn but it's not so not such a
big deal because I I enter with the King
now
I have it all covered here f 4g 4 and so
on and i hope at the end that my kin
will get to see three and it's erith
everything's on light squares
them cannot covered
yeah yeah this was quite nice positional
game it's um he probably should
shouldn't exchange but I mean this is
not losing but it's very one-sided this
position because I have a good king is
on these successes are all nice um and
he's got a point B 3 this is sam this is
not easy the structure it's really a
different story if you have the pawn
let's say if the poem would be on on a
two and then there's not much going on
and especially point A to point B to
everything back then there's not much
going on here I can really press a bit
it's a it's it's quite quite an annoying
position to defend here I have multiple
options also taking is good on 84 maybe
maybe this is better even to take on a
format okay it looks it looks good yum
okay thanks for watching